I got seven kids and seven baby mamas
now for the past few days I've been
going live telling my story speaking my
truth and a lot of women having an issue
calling me a deadbeat because I tell
them I was being irresponsible yeah not
wearing protection but I always tell uh
these women that I got pregnant that I
do not want to be a father to these
children and I offer to pay for the
abortion majority of times they'll
either take the abortion or they'll take
a plan B but only these seven have kept
these children holy souls
Hey listen listen I could be forgiving
to this rhetoric if it was one woman
seven
only seven have kept it that means he's
gotten a lot of other women pregnant
guys I don't think you guys are aware I
don't know if you guys know this but an
abortion is a [__] up thing to have to
go through physically I don't think you
guys realize the kind of Burden you
place on the other person in terms of
hormone imbalance in terms of mental
health in terms of physical health like
how much it [__] them up to have to go
through an abortion yeah Plan B that's
all so bad too it'd be [__] up people
when you're messing with people's
hormone levels and putting everything
out of wagon messes up their weeks
sometimes much longer so you have to
understand you guys can't use that as a
form of common birth control is one
thing if there's an accident that
happens or whatever you guys take care
of it that way but it can be a
reoccurred thing where you expect that
your partner and then act that entitled
if you feel so strongly about not having
kids go get a vasectomy stupid well you
know you're getting seven wooden
pregnant don't sorry you got many more
women pregnant but you mad at the seven
who kept the kid like yo if you're that
[__] irresponsible and you want to
bust nuts inside of all these women
you're a loser deadbeat it's like listen
if you want to do the pull out man but
you having that much failure that means
you're not pulling out at all you really
[__] stupid pull out don't work pull
out of this risky it's not that it
doesn't work there's plenty of married
couples who do pull outs for years you
have to know what the hell you're doing
you have to know her ovulation cycle
there's ways to actually do it properly
but if you're doing random hookups
there's very little cheats you're going
to be aligning everything perfectly yeah
and here's the thing about the pull-up
method the problem isn't even the
pull-out method you wanna know what the
real issue is it's going for round two
because they're still yeah there's still
[__] loaded in the chamber there's
gunpowder residue yeah and that ends up
coming out afterwards right and so it's
one of those things where if you don't
know what you're doing you're gonna make
it worse I'm not here advocating for it
and what I'm trying to say is if you're
gonna do this this often to be this
irresponsible not have conversations
about birth control with the people
you're hooking up with don't expect me
to sit here and have your side you
[__] crazy seven different women you
are a deadbeat only seven he said that
only seven that's how irresponsible you
are that's so casual you were [__]
dead like there's a good argument to be
made that there's something unfair about
the fact that you and a woman can have a
conversation decide to not have kids
sleep together and she changes her mind
and you're on the hook there's a real
conversation about that but I will not
use irresponsible case studies like this
[__] loser who's gotten how many
different women pregnant and your acts
entitled to a plan being abortion if I
was in that situation there's no way I'd
be able to talk that comfortably to
somebody I did that to because I
understand what she's gonna have to go
through in order to get rid of it so
there's a little bit of humility that
you have to have to demand so much if
you're that if you think it's that easy
to go through that then go get your ball
sniffed it is reversible many of the
times
go get your ball snipped
means the tone that you're coming at
this word with you like these [__]
supposed to what it's reversible when
they do Clips but when they couldn't end
when they couldn't burn it's not that
reversible but yeah but they're not
smart that's more confident it's more
what yeah they do that if you want that
you can get the one that is reversible
if you want the one that's permanent
then you just get that one but generally
speaking the ones who do it here in
North America are getting the reversible
ones this video is brought to you by
surf shark no matter where I'm at all
right whether it's uh in my house or in
my Airbnb one on my way or in Antarctica
or or even when I'm taking a [__] I need
to have access to all my programs hey
but sometimes the internet doesn't allow
me for that because it's restricted
because of the area that I'm in
yeah and for that I need a system that
allows me to change my location
and that's called a VPN changer yes in a
wonderful VPN that I'm using is surf
shark and it allows you to just change
the location of where you are and you
can watch everything that you want no
matter where you're at right now with
Surfside you can just use promo code
Abba and preach and you're gonna be able
to have 83 off plus there's a plus
three months extra free
I know crazy get on it me to be
responsible financially emotional
spiritually mentally or physically with
some kids I do not want and I don't give
up when nobody think about it you're not
going to force children up on me yeah we
both made the decision to lay down and
have intercourse we both was
irresponsible about the decisions we
made that night yeah I could have pulled
out but I didn't and I ain't care to
pull out because
yeah sorry sorry that's a Smoking Gun
you a deadbeat loser
yeah I could but I did what and I don't
care how how toughy acting in his car
let me tell you the government gonna
come for that ass they gonna find a way
is he saying that he's not paying child
support
oh he said I don't care so I'm assuming
he's not paying child he's running out
somehow the only reason you can be this
loud and this happy and upbeat or
whatever the [__] he is is because
you're not paying child support for
seven kids that's what that means that's
the only way you could be this loud and
arrogant they do that because if you was
talking like this and I played this
[__] video in court
before y'all say oh he irresponsible
he'll deadbeat he don't take
accountability yeah I do I just don't
give a [__] you ain't gonna Force these
children on me when I told you I ain't
want them yeah I can offer to a pay for
abortion but at what point can I force a
woman to go get an abortion I cannot a
woman say my body my choice but I say
it's my life my choice before y'all try
to stitch this stupid like black man
this black man that I don't give
I really don't but you gave a [__] it up
to make this video and you don't give a
[__] when you're in child support court
there's no way you have seven different
kids with seven different Mamas and this
[__] is true and they're not taking you
to court there's not a [__] chance in
hell they're gonna find a way to get
that money and you end up going pay
because the government always gets the
cash and they always because the
government don't want to be paying for
these people to go on welfare full-time
so they want you to subsidize part of it
because you're irresponsible Behavior
led to this child's creation and this
child does need their parents to be able
to financially provide for them so the
government will come for that ass I
don't believe him for a second and they
and they take that very seriously these
states they take that very soon they'll
jail your ass
like I said I got sympathy for folks who
get into this situation once I do
because I understand how we can be
unfair to men in terms of family court
but seven my [__] no no no no no no no
no now you are you are one of the many
problems in the black community [__]
who go around here getting multiple
because listen listen listen I know many
more dudes you got multiple baby mamas
and women got baby daddies okay so you
guys are the ones creating a lot of
these fatherless homes right that's
y'all
that's y'all this kind of entitlement
this kind of like I don't like that's
you guys
no it's it's only seven kept them
it's not if not he did that seven times
yeah oh yeah he didn't do that seven and
any woman who gets pregnant by him now
after seeing this [__] you also a
deadbeat loser too I'm sorry he showed
you who he was if you out here getting
pregnant by a loser like this you need
to hold this up everybody can get it
everybody can get it because we can sit
here and talk about what's right or
wrong blah blah blah there's kids being
born
there's people who are going to be born
in these [__] up circumstances because
of people being that irresponsible yeah
well the one we could get yeah guys
sorry abortions and all that [__] you
shouldn't look at it as as birth control
if you feel that strongly you should
take the precautions to make sure that
[__] don't happen and if it does you
should own up to that [__] to some
degree it's some [__] up [__] to do it
really is it really [__] is I don't
think they understand what it entails
and
whatever the person that does that goes
through it's some [__] up [__] it's
just this kind of talk is just crazy
yeah that's that's right here guys be
like what women can do it and then I
hear I'm like you feel so strongly go
get the operation get your ball snipped
go take the male forms of birth control
you have that option too now that you
want to have as much fun as possible so
there's entitlement to fund as much but
not respond responsibility happy [__]
is not getting tested making sure you
good when you're getting [__] these
people you're not asking them to get
tested so nobody paying attention nobody
everybody is like engaging in their own
little form of self-pleasure which is I
want to think about what's best for me
and put all the responsibility of
everything else on the other person how
much is a vasectomy
kill yourself
it's like we're having this whole
conversation men women men women it's
like God damn there's kids
it's really that it's kids like it
this is one of those where you know I'm
often on the dude side regards to a lot
of these issues but I'm like bro you you
100 a deadbeat loser Debbie loser and I
believe this story is not true because
if he's not paying child support for all
these women they're gonna get him they
go get them there's no way you're
getting away with it that's self
solution right there yeah do the tape
now they're gonna find you you can't
hide forever to take down
you're doing that thing online you're
putting in someone recorded that yeah
someone recorded that yeah
anyways let us know what you guys think
in the comments below I want to hear
from you he said only seven kept them